When you do coffee animals, any special instructions if you have an iliostomy
Can you make essential oils like frankincense or lemon grass at the same time?
So if you have an iliostomy, you can still do a coffee animal because you're not doing a coffee animal to
To to remove contents in your rectum
That's not what you're doing a coffee at the end of before. You're not doing a coffee animal to remove
contents in your descending colon
You're doing a coffee animal to stimulate the vagal nerve, cranial nerve, tend in the rectum
That's the purpose of doing a coffee animal. Now it can have side benefits if you don't have an iliostomy that you will
You know have bubble milk to you could possibly clean out sludge if you could possibly, you know help help with
constipation
But the purpose of doing a coffee animal is to stimulate
cranial nerve tend
Cradial nerve tend is your vagal nerve. That's another name for it. Your vagus nerve or vagal nerve
And it stimulates your parasympathetic nervous system. That's the whole purpose of doing a coffee animal is parasympathetic
stimulation
So you will you stimulate your parasympathetic you're stimulating your immune system
You're stimulated detoxification pathways. You're stimulated reset relaxation. You're stimulated
Decrease inflammation in the brain all sorts of great things. You're doing when you're stimulating the parasympathetics
also if you go to our website and you just start typing it in the search bar parasympa just start typing that and you're going to see
parasympathetic sympathetic
exercises to stimulate your parasympathetic and other set of exercises to
To calm your sympathetic which are the opposite side of that immune response. So use those two
Can you use essential oils in your
In your coffee animal. Yes, but I've always said that it's kind of waste
The essential oil because how much are you, you know, it's mixed in with water
If you're only holding it for 10 minutes
Are you absorbing any of that? Are you affecting the cold at all? I don't know maybe you are but
Probably not very much because you're just voiding
And you're just dumping it all in the toilet. So I don't I mean you came but I don't know there's that much in benefit tonight
I also tried the cold brew version of the hot method
It seems that the cold brew is not as strong a mixing one tablespoon to
Well, 10 ounces of warm water for the cold brew
Yeah, if you're doing the cold brew method if you're doing cold brew and then mixing it to water
The whole idea is that that caffeine. So that's the whole idea of using the coffee and above brand coffee that we sell
For coffee animals. It's extremely light roasted. You certainly want to want to drink it
It's taste horrible. It's just extremely caffeinated
So that's the idea behind that. So yeah, you want the caffeine as if you can tolerate it